when we first learn about cells because
of the visualizations that we often see
in textbooks or even some of the the
micrographs we might see from
microscopes we kind of imagine cells as
these little balloons of fluid with
things floating around in them so this
right over here this is a fairly common
textbook visualization of a
cross-section of the cell and we see all
of these important parts we see the
nucleus we see the endoplasmic reticulum
we see the we see the Golgi apparatus we
see mitochondria here and the way that
this is drawn it looks like they're just
floating it looks like they're just
floating in the cytosol and it is true
that there is a lot of water in cells in
fact you are mostly water and most of
that water that makes up you is found in
cells but it turns out that these types
of drawings are missing a very crucial
aspect of the structure of cells they
are missing the cytoskeleton saito
cytoskeleton and this is still something
that we we are trying to understand
better of what how does the cytoskeleton
work and how does it help the cell have
its structure and move things around and
give it its shape so cytoskeleton it's
one word but I've written the different
parts of the words and the different
parts of the word in different colors
here because this literally means cell
skeleton so if I were to actually try to
visualize the cytoskeleton here I have
all sorts of these structures just in a
different color and have all sorts of
these structures Criss crossing the cell
in different ways that have proteins
bound to them and they're even moving in
they're growing in there they can help
the cell move around or they can help
transport things within the cell and
other things could be lodged in them and
so it's a much much much more complex
thing that we're talking about than what
was depicted in this in this in this
visualization before I had my chance to
to scribble on it and to help us
visualize and I found this picture it's
public domain picture and I found it
fascinating because it really helps you
think about the complexity that is going
on in even one of your cells so let's
look at some of the structures over here
so this these this thing that I'm kind
of that I'm kind of tracing that I'm
kind of tracing right over here this is
called a micro filament this is a micro
filament
so let me write that that's a micro
microfilament and just to get a sense of
the scale its diameter so this diameter
is going to be about six or seven
nanometers so approximately six to seven
nanometers six to seven billionth of a
meter and have just got a sense of that
relative to the cell itself a typical
cell could be it could be six to seven
micrometers in diameter or larger so
this is essentially one thousandth of
the diameter of the cell so these these
things that I'm drawing right over here
these actually would not be that far off
in terms of scale in fact I'd probably
want to draw it even thinner and that's
why you often won't see in these
diagrams because you'd have to draw it
you would have to draw it so thin the
diameter of one of these filaments is
one is roughly or to remand to mm of the
diameter of a of a fairly typical cell
but these things are incredibly
important they help give the structure
of the cell they're made up of they're
made up of actin proteins so you can see
there's kind of these two actin these
two actin you can kind of visualize them
as ropes wrapped around each other and
so this the protein involved here let me
do this I'm using that color too much
the protein involved in these
microfilaments is actin this is actin
and what's neat about these
microfilaments I sell they as I said
they help give structure they help do
all sorts of things they can actually be
dynamically kind of destroyed and
created their lengths can be changed
this can help a cell actually move and
even more you can use them you can
transport things along them where you
could pull and tug on them and there's
actually a fascinating interaction
between actin and what you see over here
this this right over here this is made
up of myosin this is myosin my let me
write this and it's hard to see that is
myosin myosin and the relationship with
actin myosin myosin can act as kind of
this thing that kicks along the myosin
and can they can move relative to each
other this is essential for muscles
contracting it's fascinating to see that
even things like proteins which are just
made up of a bunch of amino acids they
can interact and the
fairly complex ways that you can have
these myosin things kick along and move
and tug on on the actin so that's myosin
right over there we see we see ribosomes
these ribosomes are the ribosomes that
are not attached to the endoplasmic
reticulum so these are free ribosomes
around here so you can see it's
incredibly incredibly complex you might
say okay I see I see these micro
filaments made up of made up of actin I
see one the one I outlined there's
others over here I see another one right
over here I see one up over here but
what are these big what are these big
tube-like structures that we also see so
for example what is this what are these
tube-like structures well these are
called micro tubules so micro micro
tubules and they look massive compared
to the microfilaments but they're still
really small on a cellular scale this is
about 25 nanometers 25 nanometers and
once again these play a huge role in the
structure of cells and they allow things
to be organized and things to be
transported and these are also dynamic
pieces of the cell they can be
constructed and they can be destroyed
and they can change the shape of the
actual cells and in animal cells the
things I've just described are found in
most cells but in animal cells you will
also find things called intermediate
filaments that are actually in between
these two in size which also help
maintain shape and do other things so
the whole point of this video is to just
give you even more appreciation
hopefully all the other videos we had on
cells I've given you appreciation for
how much beauty and how much complexity
there are and things that a lot of times
on an everyday level we think of is
something as simple as a cell but
there's all this beauty and complexity
to its structure that's often not even
depicted in the drawings of the cells
that you might find in your textbooks
and to get a better appreciation here
some public domain images I found of
cells where you can see the cytoskeleton
actually colored in and what you see in
this picture in particular in this
yellowish green color those this is
actually cow lung cells right over here
this yellowish green structure these
these yellow screen lines you see those
are the microtubules and what you see in
this
pinkish or oranges color these are the
microfilaments oh you get a appreciation
for how complex and and and structured
these things that you used to think
we're just big blobs actually are